[Music]
given a plaque of wood
some tools what furniture would you
design to tell your story
a lot of people thought it was crazy
choosing to join the sunset industry
like carpentry
in singapore is very very different as
compared to overseas
so if you see overseas you can see them
taking pride in the woodworkers you see
them
celebrating these book workers but in
singapore it's a bit different
there isn't as much credit given to the
craftsman
rajen sun is a family business when it's
a family business and knowing that my
two other brothers are involved
it's like putting all the eggs into one
basket if the company fails
the whole family fails
[Music]
even before like it was set in stone
that we were taking over the company
when my dad was diagnosed with cancer
i already knew that i was going to join
the family business
it was just a matter of time taking over
the business
learning from the ground up i think that
was a that was one of the biggest
challenges we had
it was very difficult for us to go out
to our suppliers you know and gain their
trust because
the supplies see three young boys and
then they think like you know you're
doing an fyp
or you know you're just like an intern
[Music]
when we took over the business we
rebranded and then we changed
we changed our business model as well so
it was a bit difficult
because i mean it's in human nature to
be resistant to change your body really
love change right
a good furniture firstly has to fit well
in the sense it has to fit your body
well it has to fit the room well
the design process into crafting
something
erogen science mainly revolves around
three main factors
so will be form functionality and
aesthetic
we pay close attention to every single
detail
right down to the meticulous level of
what kind of screws we use
what kind of joints we use we try to
build something that lasts rather than
something that's fast furniture
something that will be able to be passed
through generations to be
somewhat similar as an aloo thank you to
us most of the time it's
um we will ask them you want this dining
table
in like a japanese kind of design or you
want it in a scandinavian kind of design
mid-century
the other things we would need to ask is
let's say um there are certain kinds of
material they want to use so what kind
of wood you want to use
rain tree every day in the whole of
singapore
there is about 100 trees getting chopped
down in the next 15 years there's going
to be 15 000 trees getting chopped up
so with that being said there's a vast
amount of trees getting chopped down
these trees that are chopped down they
are felt they are mainly for two reasons
for
new development or they are a safety
hazard so there is this vast amount of
trees there
so what's the point of us importing wood
when there is this
stockpile of material that we are able
to use that's where the local tree
project grew
the three that we get a lot is angsana
which is brown red ish the other one is
kaya kaya is mahogany and then we have
entry ring tree we call it asia mona
back in the 80s singapore didn't have
enough trees right so what they did was
they took a bunch of trees from africa
and brought over to singapore and they
planted them here that's why
kaya has this red hue to it because it's
bhagavan
in order for us to really push local
tree project
further what we had to do is to know the
material even more
and that's why we did our ind research
and development learn more about the
material so let's say
angsana is better for indoor kayak is
better for outdoor
from there when we learn more about the
material we learn the technical specs of
it it's easier for us to
know if let's say a a deck chair that's
going to be
next to a swimming pool what kind of
material can we use what kind of
material should we avoid
we also work towards identifying the
material
so let's say the material is weak
outdoors what we can do is to densify
the material to make it stronger to make
it harder
sometimes when we glue two pieces of
wood or this adhesive that we use
that is high in voc voc stands for
volatile organic compound
so these are harmful to humans when you
smell it
so we try to move away from these
expendables that are high in voc
we are working with a local beekeeper
and when he extract the honey
he will take these beeswax and pass it
to us and with these beeswax we'll make
our own beeswax finish and that we can
apply
on our furniture and beeswax is very
good because meat specs is
organic you know you can eat it and
totally find it
a lot of people don't realize that some
of these trees actually they have been
in existence
longer than singapore's independence i
mean the ultimate dream is that when the
tree gets chopped down
we geotech the tree and when we geo take
the tree you know
where the tree is from so let's say we
save this table from us and you know
okay this one you key in the
attack and then you know okay this one
is actually from burdock reservoir at
this point
it preserves the history of the wood
it's a long and tedious process but it
is a very very fulfilling one
seeing the item and seeing the furniture
finally at
the client's place it brings a smile to
my face
it's a very very satisfying moment
i think design is about telling a story
and trying to build a relationship to
build that bond
to create something that's intangible
that i think is very very important
in life if we don't have things like
that it removes the romance of life that
life is just going to be very mundane
when you are drawing something that's
unconventional when it's very different
from what everybody is doing you second
guess yourself because of what people
think about you but half the time people
don't really don't think about you
[Music]
follow your heart your soul and follow
what it tells you
and then from there i mean it's easier
for you to craft your own path
[Music]
put your heart and soul into what you do
you can craft your own path
[Music]
you